en este vídeo haremos algunos ejemplos
para encontrar límites de funciones
definidas por partes que están definidas
algebraica mente como esta de acá
efe x pausa en el vídeo y traten de
encontrar los límites que nos preguntan
aquí algunos límites son unilaterales y
otros límites son regulares y otros son
límites bilaterales el primer límite es
el límite cuando x tiende a 4 para
valores mayores o iguales a 4 esto es lo
que nos indica el signo más de aquí así
que cuando x es mayor que 4 f x es raíz
cuadrada de x conforme nos acercamos a 4
desde la derecha
tenemos que considerar esta parte de la
función esto es igual a la raíz cuadrada
de 4 aún cuando x es igual a 4 y fx es
igual a esta parte la aproximación al
límite desde valores más grandes que 4
es desde la derecha por lo que usamos
esta parte de la definición de la
función así que esto es igual a 2 cuál
es el límite de fx cuando la
aproximación es desde la izquierda ahora
usaremos esta parte de la definición de
la función esto es igual a 42
entre 41 que es igual a 6 entre 3 que es
igual a 2 cuál es el límite de fx cuando
x tiende a 4 este es un buen ejemplo
porque viendo los ejemplos anteriores
vemos que cuando la aproximación es
desde la derecha y cuando la
aproximación es desde la izquierda el
límite tiende al mismo valor y sabemos
que para que un límite bilateral exista
se debe aproximar al mismo valor desde
la izquierda y desde la derecha esto se
cumple por lo que el límite es igual a 2
cuál es el límite de fx cuando x tiende
a 2 para x igual a 2
estamos en esta parte de la definición
de la función y aquí suceden cosas
interesantes cuando x es igual a 1
porque el denominador es igual a 0 pero
como el límite es para x igual a 2
entonces esta parte de la curva es
continua por lo que podemos sustituir el
valor de la función 2 + 2 entre 2 menos
uno que es 4 entre 1 que es igual a 4
veamos otro ejemplo aquí tenemos otra
función definida por partes y de nuevo
los invito a que pausa en el vídeo y
traten de encontrar los valores para
estos límites
vamos a resolverlo juntos cuál es el
límite de gm x cuando x tiende a 1
negativo desde la derecha si la
aproximación es desde la derecha para x
mayor que 1 negativo entonces usaremos
esta parte de la definición de la
función esto es igual a 2 a la potencia
menos 1 que es igual a un medio a que
será igual el límite cuando la
aproximación es desde la izquierda en
este caso estamos en este escenario de
acá por lo que esto es igual a seno de
menos uno más uno que es seno de cero y
es igual a cero aquí es igual el límite
bilateral de gm x cuando x tiende a
menos 1 en este caso tenemos dos valores
diferentes cuando la aproximación es
desde la izquierda y cuando la
aproximación es desde la derecha y
cuando esto sucede el límite no existe
cuál es el límite de gx cuando x tiende
a cero y se aproxima desde la derecha en
este caso usaremos esta parte de la
definición de la función ya que cero se
encuentra en este intervalo y en este
intervalo la función es continua por lo
que sustituimos x por cero
2 a 0 que es igual a 1 con eso
terminamos y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo